et maintenant ainsi fondu most
lancement en france bonsoir
alors vous êtes tous les deux à nouveau
réunis dans pour les fameuses petites
annonces sixième volume
elie semoun annonce la suite avec vous
deux alors il ya un casting absolument
incroyable guest-star ya arthur il ya
adriana karembeu axelle laffont dave
dany boon bernard montiel laurent voulzy
lorànt deutsch estelle lefébure et
julien clerc et on est loin des les
blondes à forte poitrine en main
d'oeuvre est voulu non mais c'est vrai
il ya un casting du diable à la
valériane ça va mieux il ya surtout nous
dire ouais hein
bien sûr tout nous deux oui c'est comme
jacques chirac toi je suis appareiller
lui la bernadette wager catherine barba
vas-y quatrième c'est bon bien donc il
ya un casting du diable sur ce truc
webo m mais dans les autres cas cette
hausse y avait plein de gens à chaque
fois il ya un paquet de gens qui veulent
tourner avec nous c'est parce que c'est
on se marre bien
c'est rigolo de se déguiser c'est vrai
tous les copains nous ont toujours moi
quand est ce que je fais un truc c'est
marrant de venir mettre une moustache ou
ou une perruque on est tous des gamins
qui viennent une robe
bien sûr on regarde oui